you know there is that piece of content
I put at like 99% of things don't matter
and everybody hits me up in the comments
and talks about what like what do you
mean like that's what I mean I mean like
you would be flabbergasted if you gave a
lot of thought to how much time you
spend on things that at a macro level
aren't bringing in any value
confrontation that has no value is a
deal breaker for me the truth is the way
I deal with confrontation something you
should think about is I think it's a
strength to not want to have negativity
in your life and so I deal with it with
one conversation and if they're not able
to adjust to what matters to me in that
then I just kind of move on and I mean
that by the way Tyler you care way less
about things than you used to right I
assume you have to now put things into
context better than you did even though
that was a strength of yours why because
there just not time for doesn't matter
yeah it's just you just realize what you
should spend your time and energy on and
what you shouldn't and 99% of the stuff
just doesn't matter